this is the world ray-traced with our TX
on and this is our TX off let's just
turn that back on there we go so the
problem with some van videos our TX
advertisements the cards are out today
by the way this is the review is that
they kind of show a picture of here's
what our TX looks like the SDK
ray-tracing global illumination all
these things and then the comparisons
are the developers just didn't enable
anything even traditional graphics
effects or at least didn't put as much
time into it as they will by the time of
game launches so it's not really the
best comparison and the marketing leaves
a lot to be desired so then we of course
turned to games benchmarking looking at
games that come out with presumably our
TX features and yet here we are a day
before launch because that's when the
reviews go up and there are none before
that this video is brought to you by be
quiet and the silent based 601 the
silent based 601 is one of the quietest
cases we've tested recently laying claim
to the crown of silence on our charts
and still manages reasonable air flow by
shipping with a pair of high quality
fans the 601 also uses well-designed
panels and unique ease of installation
features the streamlined builds includes
a well-placed dust filtration and is
large enough as a box to fit a full ATX
bill learn more at the link in the
description below
first of all quick announcement we're
gonna do a live stream on launch day or
actually on review launch day so that'll
be the day this video goes alive if
you're catching it the day it went up
their marketing for this launch its man
what did did you guys like forget how to
make charts because can we if we get a
chart on the screen from Nvidia let's
just look at the lines here there's
there's a line it says 60fps and that's
it that's the own known 262 done known
again so yeah that the charts we had a
problem with they were completely
useless they did not tell us anything
about the product they were misleading
we don't know if the scale started at 0
or started at 30 and if you're talking
about 4k 60 and acting like 4k 60 some
magical thing that's never been able to
be done before except by your own
product last year
we kind of have to question the
intentions behind them as charts final
fantasy 15 s benchmark got updated
actually the benchmark specifically how
we lambasted for being trash because it
was misleading and had all kinds of even
after nvidia fixed the while nvidia and
square enix mostly square enix let's be
honest fixed the hair works issues what
was being drawn when there weren't
actually things with hair in the screen
there was still object : LOD scaling
issues and just just general screwy
within the ffxv benchmark such that we
wrote it off as completely invalid for
testing it's not really a game we can
trust right now for an Nvidia benchmark
so then were left with things like the
asteroids demo which is very cool but
it's not a game
we're also left with the Star Wars demo
which is cool but we have no camera
control and it's not a game
technologically don't get us wrong here
the things on video is trying to do are
impressive the future of graphics will
involve some form of deep learning
almost certainly for gaming whether or
not that's here today it's a different
question but Nvidia is going the right
direction and the stuff they're doing is
impressive so marketing is making the
product look worse than it should
because it's kind of just been a really
messy disorganized sometimes misleading
launch and that's making the product
look worse than it needs to but we can't
review something on promises it's not
how so how a product purchase works
either don't buy stuff on a promise but
we'll continue talking out stuff
certainly as it comes today we're
reviewing the twenty eighty founders
edition we have a separate video coming
up today on the twenty atti founders
Edition and that'll have more
information on that card so what we're
gonna do is benchmark games that exist
on the market which he is rasterization
only presently because our TX the
namesake of these cards is not a feature
that you can yet use however the cards
are still video cards and they might in
fact be significantly better than the
predecessors even in traditional games
it's getting too taxing methodology and
test results so there'll be an article
link below check that out for all this
stuff plus a bit more in detail for
testing overall we picked each game
based on the
uses on the API uses so they were
selected for very specific reasons we
have a pretty good overall selection of
games to cover most the market and then
we also have the settings and the chart
headers to check those for graphic
settings for overclocking there's a full
overclocking section in here but for the
game overclock tests we let the fan run
at Auto so we relied upon the founders
Edition lookup table to do its own fan
speed management as opposed to just
maxing out going 100 percent and hitting
59 decibels because that didn't really
seem realistic so Auto for the fan speed
despite being manually overclocked
otherwise and that was very intentional
one more methodology note here - we're
testing with partner model 1080 TI's 10
80s things like that because we think
that most of you will have those and so
it's the best comparison if we use the
reference 1080i and 1080p forints gaps
would be wider because those coolers are
garbage and the clocks are lower as a
result so it would certainly make the
r-tx cards look better to use reference
versus reference because of the upgrades
to reference but we think it's more fair
to use board partner especially with
dual fan versus reference for the new
cards and that's what we're doing far
cry 5 uses the dunia engine developed by
Ubisoft Montreal far cry 5 at 4k has the
r-tx 28 EF e card at 59 FPS average
planting it functionally tied with the
board partner 1080i that we tested at 57
FPS average our error margins on the
graph to find room for variance but even
considering that the 1080i performs
functionally equivalently to the 28 EF e
under these settings the RT x 2080 gains
on the 1080 FTW non TI by about 30%
generationally bumped up from 45 FPS
previously Vegas 64 is in the same boat
it's about a 30% performance gain for
the r ZX card for reference the RT x
2080 leads the 980 by over 2x and leads
at the 980 TI by about 62% overclocked
in the 2080 puts that 63 FPS average at
roughly equivalent again with the
overclocked to 1080 TI
here's a frame time plot of the RT x
2080 and the gtx 1080i as these cards
perform functionally equivalently they
also make sense to compare when
considering the advantaged price
position of the gtx 980ti s
note also that a lot of Nvidia's launch
marketing for RTX has revolved around
the word experience
in big quotes well between these two the
experience is identical there's hardly
any performance difference across the
cross-section of data were showing here
and just as a reminder frame time plots
are to be read as time and milliseconds
between frame presents was 16
milliseconds equating a rough 60fps
throughput lower frame time is better
but consistency is even more important
and here they're both roughly equally
consistent so even outside of the sort
of dated FPS metrics the cards are the
same 1440p is next at this resolution
the RTR 2080 Fe runs at 105 FPS average
which places it as roughly equivalent
with the 1080 T is c2 again lows are
also within our margin for error
marking frame time does roughly
equivalent generational improvement over
the 1018 on Ti is 27% the r-tx 2080 has
a bigger improvement at 4k than 1440 but
not by much as for Vega 60 for this one
the board partner model is running
roughly equivalently to the 1080 ftw at
just around 81 fps so more or less the
same given margin of error overclocking
the 2080 fe2 plus 100 plus 800 landed us
around 111 FPS average with low as
reasonably sustained and not suffering
from inconsistencies so that's good
behavior from an overclock and note
again that the offset is not universal
so if you see plus 100 in this game it's
not the same as plus 100 in another game
because the clock that it boosts too
could be different and in this instance
plus 100 was stable in all games
whereas plus 160 was stable in some but
not all anyway the 1080 Ti that is ends
up tied again even when both are
overclocked 1080p is interesting only
for scalability purposes in Far Cry 5 at
this configuration the 28 efe runs at
138 FPS average or only 18.3% ahead of
the GTX 1080
that's a significant drop from the
previous gain even at 1440 where the
settings were shared at 4k we use
different settings slightly lower in
fact and that illustrates further
differences depending on anti-aliasing
settings and we'll look into that more
later the higher percent gains would
also reflect to lower resolution heavily
anti aliased scenarios as you're
sampling the screen X more times with
anti-aliasing less producing the same
amount of load on the render pipeline
the improvement to ROPS
here
as much of the scaling difference
between 1440p and 1080p at the same
settings Sniper Elite 4 has one of the
best DirectX 12 implementations
available and was what tipped us off to
voltage shift to asynchronous compute
performance on the Titan V this game
stands as a means to illustrate how
modern API is perform on cards with
better asynchronous operations
scheduling at 4k and high settings the
r-tx 28 efe averaged 84 FPS average with
a low is at 68 FPS for 0.1% the GTX 1080
is C 2 managed 87 FPS when stock
demonstrating again near equivalence but
it is one that exits error margins ETI
pulls ahead by 2.6 percent overclocking
to both the 20 80 and the TI cards the
cards again face equivalents we're at 91
FPS for the 2080 average and 89 average
for the 1080i with 1% 0.1% lows both
extraordinarily similar the GTX 1018 on
TI average is 66 FPS allowing the 2080 a
generational improvement of 28% not as
large of an improvement as the Titan V
led us to expect with this generation
but still an improvement
unfortunately that improvement also
comes with a massive price hike and
could be matched for a cheaper 1080 TI F
1 2018 is next this game uses the ego
engine and is built by Codemasters
standing as a good representation for
other ego engine games let's start with
a different image this is a resolution
scaling chart for f1 2018
demonstrating the performance at 1080p
1440p and 4k high with the same graphics
settings the demonstration helps us to
visualize average FPS across resolutions
at 4k the r-tx 2080 is roughly equal
with a 1080i which is actually not what
we expected we were expecting to see it
to begin to pull away at the higher
resolutions and that's something we saw
sometimes at the Titan v but it does not
appear to be reflected in this
particular game with these two cards at
4k the r-tx 28 efe performs at 81 FPS
average with loes de monster below for
all cards in this game this is roughly
tied in all metrics with the gtx 980ti
c2 it would lead the fe 1080 TI by a few
percent but that's hardly impressive and
already said why we're not testing that
overclocking both the 1080i and 2080
results in another rough equivalence at
4k scaling from twenty eighty stock over
the 1080 stock 59 FPS we're looking at
about a 30% jump marking the largest
leap we've seen generationally thus far
interestingly this particular title is a
demonstration of thermal frequency
response on the r-tx 2080 when over
clocks were running into a thermal cap
limit and dropping frames pretty hard
full fan speeds permit an additional
couple of frames per second at the
expense of 60 DBA of noise so expects
better gains on the partner models
here's another frame time plot to help
illustrate performance we're comparing
the 1080i and the 2080
despite being identified by different
names these two cards are the most
immediately similar in price again the
experience and big quotes is about the
same even when we look at frame times
instead of frame rate 1440p posts the
2080 at 134 FPS average which is about
1.8% ahead of our 1080 TI performance
then again standard deviation of the
average is approximately 0.8 FPS
resulting in functional and
observational equivalence for scaling
the 2080 is 36.7 percent faster than the
1080 keeping the same scaling at 1080p
scaling drops to 35 percent which is
still a big jump this is an instance
where the ROPS and FPU jaunt is largely
beneficial even in more traditional
rasterization for reference the 2080
outperforms the 980 by about 120 percent
marking over a 2x gain across a four
year period the 988 launched in
September on the 18th actually in 2014
shadow of the tomb Raider's next and
uses an in-house engine for the
developer it's a modified crystal engine
at 4k we measured the r-tx 2080 FBE at
54 FPS average with a low as well timed
at 46 FPS for 0.1% and 49 for the 1%
lows inversely this tightness of latency
is a good path to a smoother experience
overclocking allows the RT X 28 efe a
lead FPS of 5 or at 9% for the 1080 Ti
we're at rough equivalence by all
metrics that's within error margins the
GTX 1080 runs at 41 FPS average
affording the RT X 2080 stock card a 33%
lead 1440p post the RT x 28 yet
95 FPS average affording it a measurable
but imperceptible 2% advantage over the
gtx 980ti overclocks we see the same
behavior as before the r-tx card plants
itself at 104 FPS average or a lead of
6.7%
over the 1080i that's not a guaranteed
gain mind you and it does cost an extra
a couple hundred dollars scaling over
the 1080 is 73 FPS average allows the
r-tx 2080 a lead of 30.5% and strictly
to illustrate this point here's a glance
at 1080p for this one the gap between
the RT x28 EF e is 134 FPS average and
the 10 80s or 108 FPS average shrinks to
a twenty three point nine percent
difference the lead is dropping against
resolution as shown elsewhere note that
we also observed a significantly higher
standard deviation on the RT x 2080
overclocked card than on any of the
others this was a result of the thermal
limits being hit it's not shown here but
we measured a massive standard deviation
of seven FPS on the overclocked to 2084
perspective all other cards including
these stock 2080 had a standard
deviation of around 0.5 FPS GTA 5 gives
us another fully populated chart and
runs on the rage engine at 4k the RT x
2080 efi manages 61 FPS average marking
it as below the 1080 TI
we retested this twice actually and went
for 10 total test passes for validation
on the retesting for each device even
with all the retests the 1080 is c2 is
consistently ahead of the art CX 2080 by
5.1 percent that is far outside of our
margin for error in this game and is a
market at noteworthy improvement in the
1080 Ti eliminating the RCX 2080 from
consideration for this game the value
isn't there compared to the GTX 1080 FTW
it's about 29 percent faster but being
outperformed by a 1080 TI overshadows
this growth at 1440p we see more of the
same the 1080i outperforms the RT x 2080
by 4.3 percent
the competition is better except the
competition is also made by Nvidia Vega
64 runs closer to the gtx 1070 TI down
around 75 FPS average and we'll skip
1080p because it's more of the same
1080i outperforms the RT x 28 EF
when using a partner model for the 1080i
which what most of you probably have
overclock stepping is next you already
saw overclocking results but that was
her a frequency that was stable across
all games we also did additional testing
where we found frequencies that were
stable in just some applications but
higher overall here's our overclock
stepping chart for the RT X 28 EF e card
we learned a lot in this process full
stock we peaked at 19 50 megahertz and
average 1875 while maintaining a
temperature of 72 degrees or below or on
this later the frequency pushed to 1890
megahertz without any offsets when only
increasing the maximum power throughput
or whatever was allowed by the card at
100% as we began to increase the power
offset and the frequency offset we found
that 20 70 megahertz was our average
when under load and with a 100% fans
beat so this is all things maxed max fan
max power allowance max voltage
allowance although even though Tom
Petersson from Nvidia says it's not a
placebo slider kind of still is anyway
all this is important and terrines
frequency under boost 4.0 is dependent
upon thermals just like pascal the
all-time peak frequency here was 21 15
megahertz but we ran into power perf cap
limitations that did not permit higher
frequency it's odd because if you watch
build Zoids PCB analysis on our channel
the PCB and the BRM can withstand far
far more amperage nvidia has limited
Turing's overclocking capabilities and
current throughput severely here and in
ways which are nonlinear with its
overall improvements over the previous
generation in other words even though
there's 60 watts additional overclocking
Headroom in terms of power throughput
that is not a linear translation from
the previous generation we would expect
more than that even though it's more it
doesn't percentage-wise it's not all
that much more regardless we also
managed an 800 megahertz stable memory
offset and these stats were only true
while operating at 59.4 DBA with 100%
fan speeds mind you allowing auto fan
speeds to take control we hit thermal
limits hard at 20 40 megahertz a few of
the cells in this chart are highlighted
for thermal and frequency response
you'll see those tags yellow just like
Pascal terrain drops clocks
as temperature increases even if it's
well under the new 87 degree throttle
point up from the previous 83 84 ish we
noticed that the temperature below 63
degrees when it gets there anyway would
permit higher frequencies averaging
around 20 70 megahertz instead of 20 55
megahertz we also noticed this trend
apply at 75 degrees Celsius diode
temperature pushing frequency down again
to 2040 megahertz and then modulating
between that and one step up
speaking of noise here's a chart of the
RTF twenty eighty founder Edition rpm
based fan noise will show comparative
noise normalized thermal data versus
previous generation 1080i coolers
momentarily the fans have a maximum fan
speed of approximately 4200 rpm only
when bursting up but will stop and stay
at 3700 rpm when manually set to 100%
and left alone for a second the minimum
fan speed on the FE card is 41% you
cannot go below that it does not have a
zero spin mode which is about 1500 rpm
at the minimum fan speed we observed an
idle noise output of about 30 4.8 DBA in
a room with a noise floor of 26 DBA
pretty damn quiet
we measured 40.3 DBA at 52% fan speed
which is the speed we used for noise
normalized thermal testing that will
show in a moment I want a hundred
percent speeds which are required for
peak OC performance we measured a noise
level of 59 point four
DBA that's pretty damn loud that's about
where Vega is for the reference card
about the Titan V about Titan XP most
commonly during gaming workloads the
card will operate maximally around 44 to
46 DBA depending on how hot your case is
because it will boost depending on that
four perspective we also have this chart
a different one to illustrate where and
videos fan curve stands in comparison to
some of its previous products though our
GX 28 efe fan curve verse acoustic
response is less aggressive than the
overly loud Titan XP and the desperately
hot Titan v coolers sitting closer to be
1070 F equal or in comparative data
moving into thermal testing and will
start with the frequency thermal
response on a full stock our TX 28 EF e
card this is data for a card that hasn't
been torn apart and is exactly as you'd
receive it from the factory with no
changes to anything over a 30 minutes
mark test we observed frequency decay at
key temperature thresholds with drops
primarily around the 60 to 63 degree
mark and again in the 70s you can see a
slight frequency fall out from 1965
megahertz to 1895 megahertz by the end
of the test which is normal behavior for
Nvidia's gpus with these 3.0 and has we
can see now 4.0 this chart a different
one again shows the fan speed at versus
GPU core thermals the fan ramp begins
late starting at around 68 degrees
Celsius for core temperature after that
point it ramps to about 1800 rpm and
remains there as the GPU is within
operating spec for the fan speed versus
temperature lookup table and go higher
if the GP core and warmer like it did in
firm work comparatively and always
normalize thermals for the r-tx 2080 fe
aren't completely terrible keep in mind
that this card draws a lot less power
than the TI which we'll talk about
momentarily and then again later but
still is relatively power-hungry in some
and for clarity TI there is in reference
to the 1080 TI not the 2080 we don't
presently have the other r-tx device
data but we'll be adding atom board
partners as we test their cards for now
we offer an incomparable comparison
against previous generation designs
strictly for some perspective the art CX
2080 at 40 DBA of noise for all devices
manages a reasonable GPU temperature of
49 degrees Delta C / ambience we monitor
ambient temperatures second to second
and calculate a delta minus so this is
closer to around 72 degrees in hard
measurement that puts the 2080 as better
than the dismal 1080 TI armor and Titan
XP blower the Titan XP is the most
direct comparison it's a large high TDP
device made by Nvidia with an Nvidia
reference design and it's beaten
thoroughly in thermals by the 2080 Fe
despite being a different GPU core
itself with different die sizes so that
matters again you can't strictly compare
these things but for purposes of getting
some perspective on Nvidia coolers
generationally it does help the EFI runs
significantly warmer than most of the
1080 TI partner models but it's also
completely different
so anyway use the the results as you may
the point is though that board partner
cards will do this a lot better most of
them and we'll look at those soon enough
for VR I'm MOSFET temperatures we stuck
thermocouples all over the card and
measured AVR emboss temperature from
the hottest center mosque of about forty
six point nine degrees Celsius over
ambient making this better than the amp
extreme 1080i armor and the Titan V but
worse than all the partner Model T is
from last generation finally vram
temperature is completely incomparable
and a like-for-like as we're now looking
at G GD r6 rather than g5 x for this we
measured a temperature of fifty seven
point two degrees delta T over ambient
which is within GTR sixes operating
range and is reasonable so getting into
the conclusion then quick note on power
consumption we did just a an ad-hoc
current clamp on the PCIe connectors
didn't measure the socket so we don't
know the the power coming out of the
PCIe socket but for the connectors the
28 EF e sticks at about 15 absence and
locks their four PCIe input and it does
not move so that's partly boost 4.0 it's
partly a power or current limitation and
you can go pass that with overclocking
but otherwise 15 amps multiplied by
about 12 point to on that power supply
to get your wattage the 1080i SC to that
we tested was closer to 16 to 17 amps so
it's actually more power consumption to
get equivalent performance to the 2080
from the PCIe connectors what we don't
know is did the slot change because if
the if there's more power coming out of
the PCIe socket then it's kind of a wash
but we'll look into that more later
perhaps so that's the power behavior the
card as a whole look it's out of state
in the beginning it's it's easy to get
carried away with disliking everything
about the r-tx launch because of how
disorganized end video was in its public
presentation and how misleading a lot of
the charts word that I think has pissed
off a lot of the community there is also
existing concern that is deep-rooted
from potential Hardware lock-ins
how well does Pascale do with these
things how old is AMD do with these
things the answer if RT X SDKs ever get
used is probably not very well depending
on how they're implemented but this is
all stuff we know and so there are a lot
of reasons to be concerned about the
product and about the launch about RT X
in general the card even if we a hundred
percent ignore all of those other
reasons ignore marketing
every problem you've ever had with
Nvidia put it all aside how are the
cards and the answer is the r-tx 20/80
founders edition is not worth buying
today it's more expensive than a 1080i
partner card it's hotter than a 1080i
partner card power is more or less a
wash and the gaming performance it's
identical so there there is a
generational gain 20 80 to 1080 yes it's
also a price game look at the tea I will
talk about this more in the TI review
for the 20 80 TI $1200 for the founders
Edition and most partner cards
technically yes there's $1000 MSRP we
don't know anything about those cards
right now most of them are 1,200 bucks
and the founders Edition is 1200 as well
that's what you're buying to water cool
most likely so 1200 dollars versus a 650
$700 1080i in the u.s. that's absolutely
available we checked that's something
like a 60 70 percent price increase and
the performance increase is closer to 20
to 30 and we'll talk about that again
more in the ti review so how do you how
do you justify that where where do you
find the only justification is buying on
a hope that you can use all this cool
art tech stuff and that also the game
developers don't just keep doing what
they've always done and make the games
look pretty damn good and cheat the
effects and do things like cube maps in
the window is to make fake reflections
stuff that's tricked people for a long
time so there's a lot riding on hopes
for RTX the performance versus the price
is absolutely not there right now the
1080 TI is the the biggest competitor to
Nvidia's r-tx product launch design
videos previous product which is the
1080i if you're considering a card in
the performance class of a 2080 2084 I
don't know 800 bucks
maybe if you're lucky bit lower but we
don't know what the prices are gonna be
on the partner cards yet if it's 800 +
and you can get a 1080i for 650 get a
1080i for 650 unless you're maybe a
developer
this is where it gets different game
developers not even production users
just straight game developers or someone
who's maybe working on movies or
high-end 3d effects stuff like that
those users it makes sense and they need
to adopt it anyway for it to make sense
for gaming users but for our audience
for gamers Nexus it makes more sense
generally speaking to buy a 1080i and
not buy based on promises and hopes and
that's that's gonna be our stance on
that one the partner cards might change
things we'll look at those and on the
development side we will eventually look
into that stuff as drivers released as
Unreal Engine updates we have the
ability to do 3d modeling and ray
tracing and all this stuff and software
and as blender up days Unreal updates we
plan to revisit these these cards and
look at them from a production
standpoint but today from a gaming
standpoint is what we can look at and
it's not quite there right now so
perhaps in the future perhaps as these
technologies actually get adoption I
don't think this is really surprising to
anybody that performance is good the
product is uplifted the products are
good objectively in terms of performance
the value is terrible for the 2080 TI
and is questionable at best for the 2080
the 2080s is more tenable versus a 1080
TI then a 2080 TI is versus anything
else 1080i or 2080 because they're the
same card so in terms of performance so
I think that'll wrap it for us
performance gaps will increase as we
start switching to things like he BGA's
cards and ace uses cards because they're
gonna be pre overclocked they'll have
more power Headroom so the gains there
will be more significant the price might
also be more significant we'll visit
that soon enough but for today we're
comparing what you probably have which
is an aftermarket or a board partner TI
1080 versus these and then we'll get
into the rest later so anyway that's it
kind of kind of weak overall for the
availability of what the products
namesake is but so be it it'll come out
eventually probably more likely then
things like I guess VX AO
but that's it for this one subscribe for
more toys go to store documents nexus
net to make about mod mad
support us directly these beer glass
will be back and stock pretty soon
hopefully this week and then remember we
have a live stream today the day this
goes up at roughly 6 or 7 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time in the US and that will be
over clocking for the cards so subscribe
for that I'll see you all next time
[Music]